Cédric Mas. Les dessous de
l'infox avec Sophie Malibo,
tout à l'heure, à partir de
dix-sept heures dix TU sur RFI.
Rfi et France 24 présentent
Radio Foot International, le
Café des Sports, Annie Gasmier.
Bonjour, bienvenue dans le Café
des Sports hebdomadaires de
Radio Foot International sur
euh, RFI, sur France 24 et
grâce à Facebook live sur tous
vos écrans. Bienvenue donc dans
cette émission avec nos invités
du jour qui sont là présents
bien sûr. Bonjour Émile
Bonneau. Ah bonjour Annie et
bonjour à tout le monde et
surtout bonjour euh, à
il sera là vous vous allez euh,
le découvrir. Bonjour euh,
Xavier Barré. Bonjour Annie je
crois qu'on a pas mal de choses
à à dire aujourd'hui Oui mais
je crois qu'il y a il y a
beaucoup de choses. Je pense
qu'il il y aura pas mal de
discussions. N'est-ce pas?
Bonjour euh Bruno Constant.
Bonjour Annie, bonjour à tous.
Euh je crois que l'Angleterre
aujourd'hui sera euh en
exergue. Aujourd'hui donc euh
cette finale euh si attendue
tant attendue la finale de la
Ligue des champions ce sera
demain soir à Istanbul,
Manchester City Inter de Milan
qui se retrouve pour le dernier
grand trophée de la saison. Une
opposition de style entre
l'équipe qui fait rêver et le
savoir-faire italien et puis
entre deux entraîneurs,
Guardiola, l'un des meilleurs
du monde face aux débutants à
ce niveau qu'est Simone Zaghi,
le géant norvégien Erling
Hallande sera-t-il le buteur
qui fera basculer cette finale?
Une autre finale à Casablanca
pour la Ligue des Pains
champions d'Afrique, finale
retour après la victoire de
Al-Ahly au Caire. Le Wydad
tenant du titre pourra-t-il euh
réaliser le doublé. L'heure de
la relève a sonné en Europe.
Après le départ, ces derniers
mois de footballeurs de
légendes, de Cristiano Ronaldo,
de Léo Messi, de Karim Benzema
ou encore de Zlatan,
Ibrahimovic, quels sont les
joueurs qui feront le football
européen de demain? Quelle sera
la relève? Eh bien nous en
parlerons aujourd'hui et au
générique de cette émission,
David Finzel, qui m'a aidé à
préparer l'émission avec Pierre
Guérin et avec Fanny
Laurent Salerno est à la
réalisation. Pour ce qui est de
la réalisation vidéo et France
vingt-quatre. Le Café des
Sports, les débats sont
ouverts.
Finale d'Istanbul avec une
pelouse aux étoiles, celle de
la Ligue des champions, bien
sûr une compétition qui chaque
année en Europe révèle euh ou
réveille les stars du moment.
Cette année, celles qui ont
brillé euh sont à Manchester
City et à l'Inter Milan et
elles se retrouvent à Istanbul,
une ville qui a connu alors là
je me tourne vers vous euh
Xavier Barré, faire la mémoire,
vers l'Histoire aussi, parce
que il y a déjà eu un club
anglais contre un club italien,
en finale et à Istanbul et on
peut dire que ça a été euh une
finale pour l'histoire. Une
finale extraordinaire
effectivement entre Liverpool
et Milan, Milan qui menait
trois zéro, Liverpool qui est
revenu à 33 et qui l'a emporté
aux tirs au but. Donc une
finale inoubliable pour les
supporters des Reds et pour
tous les amateurs de football
parce que ce genre de de
scénario de scénario, on en a
on l'a pas souvent. Hum hum.
Euh Bruno c'est vrai que c'est
resté dans dans la légende de
Liverpool euh des Reds, cette
euh cette finale avec ce
renversement incroyable parce
que on a trois buts en première
mi-temps hein quand on revoit
les les chiffres surtout les
euh de de quand on marque et
finalement euh en première
mi-temps c'est Milan qui
marque, en deuxième mi-temps il
y a que Liverpool et on va
jusqu'aux tirs au but. Ouais
avec cette petite anecdote, ce
basculement qui se déroule dès
à la mi-temps dans le vestiaire
de Liverpool, quand ils
entendent les supporters des
raids chanter le alors qu'ils
sont menés trois zéro et ça les
a motivés comme jamais, ils
sont repartis sur le terrain,
comme s'il y avait zéro zéro,
ils ont recommencé la finale et
ils l'ont remporté et et c'est
c'est un souvenir fabuleux mais
comme le dit Xavier, ça va
au-delà des supporters de
Liverpool, pour moi grande
finale de l'histoire de Ligue
des champions. Euh Rémy c'est
c'est c'était dans le même
stade, c'était le stade
olympique euh Ata Turc de
d'Istanbul. Ça marque
l'histoire, est-ce que ça peut
planer au-dessus de cette
finale? Euh on va se demander
si finalement euh le le
vainqueur mener trois zéro à la
mi-temps, peut-être que on se
posera la question. Ah! Céline
Caremmeni. City est mené
troisième. Alors là, vous vous
voyez tout le monde a déjà
donné l'Inter perdant alors que
bien évidemment vous avez pu
voir ne serait-ce que même le
Liverpool qui ressemble quand
même à une poule mouillée
désormais, qui a ah oui ils
sont pas en Ligue des champions
mais vous les vous les avez vu
en en euh malgré tout vous avez
vu au moins ce que City qu'on
croyait par exemple Manchester
United euh qui déjà aussi n'est
pas à un top niveau qui a quand
même aussi tenu tête euh à City
donc pour moi une finale ça se
joue et une finale c'est
jusqu'au bout et d'ailleurs moi
pour l'instant je ne trouve pas
deux favoris que justement j'ai
souvent vu les équipes de Pep
Guardiola traînaient la patte
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une finale
aux grands enjeux. Alors
effectivement euh Rémi, vous
avez raison, une finale, ça se
joue jusqu'au bout et là on va
se retrouver avec deux équipes
où euh on va en discuter mais
euh il y a quand même deux
styles qui qui s'opposent, des
Citizens qui ont évidemment un
mode de jouet euh imprimé par
euh par leur entraîneur mais
aussi un mode euh très
particulier, spectaculaire,
avoir euh joué et aussi autour
de de la possession bien sûr et
puis en face euh eh bien on se
retrouve avec euh euh une
équipe de de l'Inter qui est
euh sans doute plus efficace
euh qui recherche la
verticalité et qui a surtout
une assise défensive. Vous
parliez euh d'Onana. Eh bien
justement le gardien
camerounais André Onana de
cette équipe et qu'on a vu
avoir tant d'importance jusqu'à
la qualification en finale. Ils
vantent cette force défensive.
C'était au micro de Matteo
Tchoffi cette semaine. Jouer
avec eux c'est pas mal. Pour
moi ces garçons sont les
meilleurs défenseurs du monde.
Donc ils sont en train de
travailler comme des malades,
ils se sacrifient, c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinaire.
Et ce que je peux apporter,
j'apporte ma petite
contribution on aura nos
opportunités et j'espère qu'on
pourra revenir avec le trophée.
Et final ne se joue pas donc
nous irons à Istanbul pour
gagner. Nous savons aussi que
on joue contre probablement la
meilleure équipe du monde en ce
moment mais devrons nous
démontrer sa musique et sont
les meilleurs parce que nous
irons à gagner. Peu importe
contre qui tu joues, je
respecte tout le monde mais je
de personne. Il n'a peur de
personne, André Onana. Bon, il
aura quand même un grand Allan
face à lui, il aura quand même
euh De Bruyne, il aura euh bien
d'autres euh étoiles de cette
de cette constellation qu'est
euh celle de Manchester City.
Rémi euh vous, j'imagine que
vous êtes plutôt dans le camp
de ceux qui pensent que l'Inter
peut faire un euh peut jouer un
un tour au au Citizen très
favori? Grâce à leur style?
Oui, parce que grâce à leur
style, et d'ailleurs, il faut
se dire que les équipes qui
jouent avec trois défenseurs
ont souvent créé des problèmes
à Pep Guardiola. Euh contre à
d'autres équipes qui sont à
plat comme le Real Madrid avec
le quatre trois trois euh
pratiquement ça se joue souvent
au niveau du milieu de terrain.
Or là je crois que City aura
affaire à un bloc qui s'est non
seulement défendre mais qui
s'est aussi attaqué parce qu'il
faut quand même se dire que
cette équipe n'a pas que des
défenseurs. C'est-à-dire que
devant vous avez déjà quand
même euh la Toron Martinez sans
pour autant oublier euh euh
vous avez par exemple quelqu'un
comme euh il ne pas beaucoup
mais peut-être il pourrait être
euh titulaire ou même aux
banques et à euh En revenant,
Lukaku, qui revient quand même,
mais qui quand on essaie de
regarder quand même les
statistiques sur l'ensemble des
des de toute la compétition
alors qu'il n'a pas beaucoup
joué. On voit quand même qu'il
est à 17 buts et 17 buts plus
l'autre ans qui bute toutes
compétitions confondues. Vous
vous rendez quand même compte
que cette équipe a des atouts
offensifs qui peuvent faire
très très mal à une défense de
même pas le total de de
Hollande cette saison euh,
toute compétition confondue.
Donc euh, l'Int a marqué euh
trente-six hein c'est ça en
toute compétition
confondue donc on met toute
compétition confondue et là euh
à Londres il est déjà à
cinquante-deux. Euh lui tout
seul. Euh maintenant maintenant
à
jeter l'autre hein bien
évidemment. Parce que Allan
bien évidemment c'est lui qui
va jouer devant. Mais bien sûr
que de l'autre côté moi je vous
dis que Inter joue avec presque
deux pointes. Donc il faut
d'abord totaliser ça et nous
avons constaté que Allan que ce
soit face au Real Madrid tous
les deux matchs il n'a pas pu
marquer, il n'a pas été
brillant pendant finale de la
FACO. Mais actuellement me
citer aujourd'hui
sur le le le les styles de ces
deux équipes euh justement il y
en a un qui qui est un peu euh
euh feu d'artifice alors que
l'autre euh est peut-être plus
dans le calcul mais finalement
euh les deux sont sont très
efficaces. D'un côté on a un
jeu de possession, on suit de
Manchester City euh installé
par Pep Guardiola depuis sept
ans maintenant d'ailleurs. Oui
mais qui sait aussi
effectivement varier, vous avez
raison, Annie de temps en
temps, il s'est joué long, il
s'est il sait euh varié euh il
s'est adapté aussi au football
anglais, il l'a expliqué très
bien d'ailleurs, et puis de
l'autre côté vous avez vous
avez Simone Zaghi qui, à la
base, est un entraîneur qui
veut la possession d'ailleurs à
la Lazio, il jouait plutôt un
football de possession, et
depuis qu'il arrivait à
l'Inter, il a été pris par la
culture de l'Inter qui depuis
les années 60 et le club qui a
inventé le quinténacho,
c'est-à-dire la défense à
outrance, avec son entraîneur
franco-argentin Elenio Herrera
à et et et ça leur colle au ça
leur colle à la aux maillots
euh euh Nerazo, ils arrivent
pas à s'en à s'en dépêtrer. Euh
depuis des années l'Inter joue
toujours comme ça, on l'a eu en
2010, avec Mourinho, c'était
une caricature mais ils ont
quand même gagné la Ligue des
champions et depuis euh ils
essayent de jouer de temps en
temps un football un peu plus,
ils voudraient jouer un
football spectaculaire, mais
c'est difficile. Ils ils
restent appuyés sur une défense
non pas à trois, mais à cinq,
un milieu de terrain très
travailleur avec des joueurs de
talent et devant effectivement
ces flèches qui vont représente
des dangers pour le pour les
Citizens. Des sacrés dangers
pour les Millanais, on les a eu
Donc vous dites là, justement,
on joue aussi avec cinq
défenseurs parce que Rodi qui
est défenseur central, eh bien
a été incorporé au milieu du
terrain. Et d'ailleurs, c'est
ça qui fait aujourd'hui la
force Aujourd'hui, a souvent
joué défenseur central, ça
c'est clair. Voilà. Je me je me
je me demande comment comment
je voudrais voir le téléviseur
chez chez je me demande comment
il les comment est sa
télévision, est-ce que ça
brouille, est-ce que il y a des
angles biaisés, est-ce que
parce que franchement on voit
pas les mêmes matchs
vous
vous regardez
particulièrement tout ce qui
est euh équipe anglaise et
championnat anglais euh quel
est votre sentiment par rapport
à cela? Parce que parce que les
les Manchester City est
finalement ultra favori, on le
sait tous et en même temps on
se pose des questions sur euh
ce jeu flamboyant, léché euh et
qui parfois montre des failles.
Beaucoup cette saison des
failles quand même hein, en
tout cas pas pas beaucoup
depuis le mois de février, moi
je trouve que c'est une équipe
de City qui est moins
flamboyante justement, un peu
moins léchée et beaucoup plus
pragmatique, beaucoup plus
cynique, elle est capable de
défendre bas, elle est capable
de jouer direct comme elle a
fait, on parlait de la FC Cup
en finale, elle marque au bout
de 12 secondes, c'est un
dégagement de son gardien, sur
la tête d'Hallande et ensuite
Google qui récupère le ballon,
donc c'est un City qui est un
peu plus malléable, qui est un
peu un peu différent et moi je
pense qu'ils ont gardé en
travers de la gorge la finale
euh, de Ligue des Champions
perdue en 2021 face à Chelsea,
vous déjoué, vous avez changé
leur manière de jouer, ils
avaient sorti Rodri, ils
avaient mis en sentinelle, ça
avait pas du tout marché, ils
s'étaient fait prendre en
compte justement par cette
équipe de Chelsea, et je pense
que Guardiola, il a appris de
ses erreurs, et maintenant il
est capable de de de s'adapter
à l'adversaire. Et je pense que
l'Inter et c'est marrant parce
que ces deux équipes ont parlé
de la différence, deux équipes
qui jouent finalement avec une
défense à trois. Parce que City
joue avec une défense à trois,
puisque le ah! Tu ne vois pas
les mêmes matchs que Xavier!
Xavier disait que c'est pas
c'est John Stones le défenseur
axial qui qui vient au milieu
jouer comme défenseur central
qui joue au milieu de terrain
la la la l'Inter leur défense
centrale elle est devant la la
surface.
latéraux aussi étaient
défenseurs central. C'est pas
la même la même dispositif
tactique du tout le dispositif
en tout cas on se retrouve donc
avec deux styles bien
différents avec un c'est
peut-être un peu calmé et euh
sur les innovations et sur le
style mais qui évidemment a
pour de l'emporter. Alors
surtout dans cette équipe de de
Manchester euh City, il y a un
joueur, même s'il y a beaucoup
de grands joueurs et de bons
joueurs, il y en a un qui
dépasse tout le monde, ça on
peut être que d'accord. C'est
euh Erling Halande, le grand
norvégien, le numéro neuf qui
impressionne. Il impressionne
depuis qu'on l'a vu à Salzbourg
en Ligue des champions euh à
l'époque hein, il avait
commencé à apparaître là, après
il y a eu évidemment Dortmund
et maintenant il y a cette
équipe de première ligue, il a
donc inscrit euh ce que vous
avez dit 52 buts cette saison.
Il a été effacé pendant les
deux ou bien marqués, pendant
les deux buts euh contre le
Real de Madrid, même si il a
euh son rôle. Est-ce que selon
vous quand même là c'est sa
finale et c'est la finale du
Facteur X euh il a été recruté
pour ça dit-on euh du côté de
Manchester City euh Bruno?
C'est lui qui le dit, il dit on
m'a pas fait venir pour euh
remporter une énième première
ligue, même s'ils l'ont fait
cette saison, mais pour la
Ligue des champions. Et moi
j'ai tiré même la la la pas les
difficultés mais on va dire une
certaine forme de discrétion
devant le but d'Hallande, à la
fin de la saison, ce sont les
quatre derniers matchs, il a
pas marqué. Alors il y a eu des
moments où c'était il a non il
a non non il a toujours été bon
dans le jeu parce qu'il est
impliqué sur les buts de son
équipe, il est impliqué dans le
jeu, il défend énormément, il
presse énormément les matchs
contre le Real Madrid par
exemple, il a pas marqué, mais
le travail qu'il fait sans
ballon, il est monstrueux et il
fait déjouer la la défense
adverse parce qu'il occupe
l'espace, parce qu'il fait des
fausses pistes, parce qu'il a
toujours deux défenseurs sur
lui, sinon si on le laisse tout
seul, il marque, donc non, non,
c'est c'est un facteur, mais
j'ai envie de vous faire une
réponse comme l'Apebire au mois
de septembre dernier après un
match contre Dortmund, il avait
dit aux journalistes, ne ne me
parlez pas de la langue,
parlez-moi plutôt de John
Stone, s'il vous plaît. Parce
que le facteur X de City cette
saison, c'est Jon Stones. C'est
son défenseur de poisson aussi,
ce cher euh non parce que John
Stones en sortant de la défense
centrale et en venant au milieu
de terrain, c'est lui qui se
retrouve libre puisque Gundoan
est pris, de Bruyne est pris
comme face au Real, Rodry est
est pressé et le seul qui était
libre avec le ballon, c'est
John Stones. Et ça lui permet
de s'infiltrer au milieu de
terrain jusqu'à la surface
adverse et de créer la
supériorité numérique au milieu
de terrain. Rémi, euh selon
vous euh sa télé. Non non. En
général, avec ses grands
cheveux euh quel euh quel
important est-ce que est-ce que
ce joueur qui est si jeune
hein, il a à peine 21 ans,
est-ce que selon vous c'est
c'est un grand rendez-vous
aussi dans sa tête et dans sa
carrière? C'est un rendez-vous
mais ça me ressemble quand même
euh à quelqu'un qui perd
beaucoup de confiance face au
but. Et c'est ça qui avant un
grand match euh pour les grands
joueurs et doutent parce que on
l'attendait pour des matchs euh
ils doutent. Ils doutent. Alors
de chaîne hein euh Rémi parce
que t'es pas rendu mais
qu'est-ce que vous êtes en
train de me raconter là? Je
vous dis les grands joueurs
c'est pendant les matchs
décisifs. On ne l'a pas vu.
Pour l'instant quand il ne
marque pas parce que il faisait
le triplé. Vous avez dit c'est
vous qui parliez. Je ne sais
pas comment est-ce que vous
voulez retirer vos paroles. Que
depuis quatre matchs il n'a pas
joué, il a participé
Ça pas fait son travail. Son
travail c'est
me dites que non non.
admirateur de Cristiano
Ronaldo. Euh les ce qui compte
pour un joueur dans une équipe
c'est de faire gagner son
équipe. C'est pas de soigner
ses stats personnels. Or,
qu'est-ce qu'il fait
effectivement, il a marqué 52
buts. Mais qu'est-ce qu'il
fait? Il fait gagner son
équipe? Il lui fait gagner le
championnat, il lui fait gagner
la coupe et peu importe qui
marque ou pas, ce qui compte
c'est que Manchester City
marque et que ce soit
Monsieur
était champion avant qu'Allah
n'arrive Manchester était déjà
en finale avant qu'Allah arrive
il y avait qu'il marquait des
buts avant qu'Allah arrive
qu'il faisait le football
Quarante centimètres
Complètement transparent là.
C'est pas possible.
Moi c'est lui qui bat le Real
Madrid, ce n'est ni David à
Manchester City oh là là.
Excuse-moi, il faut qu'il que
c'est lui qui bat le Real
Madrid et non et non pas le
Real Madrid un seul joueur si
c'est ta si c'est ta vision du
football c'est pas possible. Et
pourquoi vous parlez donc
on ne bat pas le Real Madrid
avec un seul joueur ça veut
dire le personnage qui fait
basculer, ça veut pas dire
qu'il au Real Madrid. le
collectif a été l'homme
essentiel pour le dernier match
et j'ai dit contre le Real
c'était Bernado Silva, c'était
moi dans les quatre derniers
meurtres entre celui qui marque
et toute l'équipe qui permet à
celui qui marque. N'était pas
bon. Bon alors qu'il pas
d'accord Simone, euh et euh
l'entraîneur de l'Inter euh
Milan, alors on sait que pour
Bob Guardiola, ce titre et même
ce triplé serait tellement
important euh nous avons
légende Lula de Bamako hein au
Mali qui nous dit carton vert
pour Guardiola en cas de succès
demain car il serait le premier
entraîneur à faire des deux
triplés avec euh des clubs
différents. Donc effectivement
ce triplé tend la main à
Guardiola et évidemment à tout
le club de City. Mais Simone
euh Xavier Barré, c'est vrai
que c'est un entraîneur euh il
vient d'arriver euh à l'Inter
Milan, il n'a pas été champion
avec eux. Par contre il vient
de gagner euh il a gagné deux
coupes d'Italie quand même euh
des finales hein euh récemment
avec la Lazio c'était euh plus
précisément. Est-ce que selon
vous il peut bénéficier de ce
qu'on dit être la chance du
débutant? Bah il est il est
quand même sur un banc en
Italie depuis un moment euh
du football de ce côté-là c'est
c'est comme Pep Guardiola son
frère qui lui éphémère
entraîneur de 2000 ans, pipeau
euh mais euh probablement plus
réfléchi de Simone et du coup
il a il a plus travaillé ses
sur euh son rôle d'entraîneur
et et du coup c'est devenu un
entraîneur vraiment respecté.
Moi ce que je trouve ce qu'il
fait à l'Inter c'est quand même
assez euh ça mérite
effectivement un coup de
chapeau parce que il a pris un
club qui était un peu en crise,
des propriétaires qui avaient
plus les moyens de leurs
ambitions, ils ont dû fait avec
ce qu'il a et il arrive à faire
cohé absolument, ils ont
récupéré Lukaku qui était en
échec à à Chelsea, donc ça
c'est un beau cadeau que leur
fait Chelsea. Ils ont euh ils
ont récupéré derrière des
joueurs d'expérience qui qui
tiennent bien la baraque, ils
ont récupéré aux nanas aussi
qui étaient en fin de contrat à
l'Ajax, c'est quand même un
super gardien. Non, ils ont ils
ont ils ont une équipe
cohérente, pas spectaculaire,
mais cohérente. Après, pour
arriver là, ils ont quand même
eu un des concours de
circonstances extrêmement
favorables. Euh en phase de
poule, déjà, il faut rappeler
qu'il se qualifie parce que ils
ont un un but refus valable
refusé au Barça lors du match
contre Mi ensuite en quart de
finale contre Porto et contre
Benfica, il passe mais vraiment
à la bagarre, surtout contre
Porto, c'est pas une équipe moi
qui me fait plaisir à voir
jouer, mais c'est une équipe
qui effectivement se bat avec
ses arguments. C'est un genre
d'entraîneur qui pourrait gêner
euh Pep Guardiola dans dans
dans sa dans sa tactique euh
disons le gêner parfaitement
euh Bruno? Oui, parce que face
au Milan AC militaire était pas
forcément favori, et
tactiquement il a dominé euh
euh le Milan, euh il est aussi
dans un groupe qui était, on
disait le groupe de la mort en
face avec le Barça, avec le
Bayern, il s'en est sorti. Moi,
pour moi, c'est un exploit
énorme, alors peut-être pas la
petite porte, mais quand on a
l'Inter face au et au Bayern,
forcément, c'est c'est
compliqué, mais il en est
sorti. Donc pour moi, c'est une
grande réussite. Et après, il a
une trajectoire étonnante parce
que toute la saison, quasiment,
il a été critiqué euh à l'Inter
et en Italie, par par sa
manière de jouer, où les
résultats en en Série A étaient
pas bons, et puis il y a eu en
parallèle ce parcours en Ligue
des Champions, qui a fait
remonter sa côte, et petit à
petit, les supporters se sont
mis à l'aimer à nouveau et à
croire en lui. Donc il a un
parcours extraordinaire et et
effectivement quand on parlait
de la chance du du débutant,
moi ça m'a fait tout de suite
penser à avec Chelsea en
deux012. Exactement. Qui était
là que pour quelques mois. Hum.
Et il a remporté euh face au
Bayern de cette Ligue des
champions avec ceci. Rémy euh
il y a euh Ygui Maduré de
Douala au Cameroun donc et qui
nous dit l'Inter avec dans ses
rangs un Camerounais n'a jamais
perdu une finale de la Ligue
des Champions. On sait qui est
le Camerounais, c'est pas vous.
Euh qu'est-ce que vous pensez
vous de de de cette euh inter
euh de Simone Zaghi? Sachez que
l'Inter de Mourinho ne partait
pas favori face au Barça. Bien
sûr. Il y a pas de Guardiola?
Bien sûr. En en demi-finale. Ah
en fin de compte, même en
infériorité numérique, Barça
out. Donc cet Inter, comme on
dit justement Et à cette époque
et cette époque il y avait un
certain Camerounais Etto. Donc
euh
maintenant, maintenant tu me
dis, tu me et tu vois
heureusement que tout de suite
là que cette terre est quand
même sortie d'une euh d'un
groupe où on ne voyait pas. Et
c'est mérité. Tu ne peux pas me
dire qu'on que est sorti par la
fenêtre devant le Bayern ou
encore devant le Bayern et ils
ont eu bel et bien à jouer et à
se retrouver en finale. Et pour
moi aujourd'hui c'est de la
même façon que j'avais vu le
peuple le Manchester City de
Pep Guardoula. On était ici. On
commentait et moi je disais ce
city face à Chelsea va échouer.
Et Pep Guardiola et on est en
train de dire la même chose je
me suis retrouvée à avoir
raison que pas le gibier sans
le feu. Tu avais vu
l'élimination du réel face au
Mancher City de de Guardiola du
coup? Je me souviens plus. Mais
c'est et c'est on va écouter
euh le l'opinion eh bien de de
passionnés de football qui
suivront euh la finale donc
demain soir euh eux ils la
suivront à Paris devant leur
télévision. Un micro-trottoir
réalisé par notre stagiaire
Fanny Volley. Je vois euh
Manchester City gagner, pas
forcément euh facilement mais
quand même je pense qu'ils
auront l'avantage. Dans
l'historique Manchester City
euh Ligue des Champions ils
l'ont jamais gagné. Peut-être
que dans la tête ça va jouer.
Ils l'ont déjà gagné. Il y a
peut-être un petit peu de euh
de mental euh Ah on pense quand
même City, Manchester City et
puis bon avec euh but de
Hallandes et des passes
décisives de Bernado Silva, on
y croit, on y croit vraiment.
Alors euh étant italien, je
veux dire deux un Inter. Et
parce que là les Italiens euh
ça fait deux fois qu'ils
perdent en finale euh. Et ouais
ouais, faut gagner la dernière.
Ce sera la loose. Voilà, avis
partagé hein, il y en a pas que
pour Manchester City et ça doit
être rassurant pour euh Rémi,
les Camerounais et euh pour
l'Inter Milanv. Match donc à
suivre sur RFI, n'oubliez pas,
ça sera à partir de
vingt-et-une heures, dix9
heures en temps universel, avec
Cédric Desolives qui se trouve
à Istanbul. Hugo Moisson qui
seront ici à Paris et qui y
répondront à toutes vos
questions. On continue parce
qu'il y a une autre finale
durant le week-end, une autre
finale continentale.
Alors autre continent et autres
formules aussi parce que cette
finale euh continentale se
déroule en match aller-retour
et là les matchs euh les pardon
marqués à l'extérieur comptent
encore double la la
confédération africaine a
maintenu ce régime pour ce qui
est du continent africain et
voilà donc la finale retour
confrontation entre un club
marocain et un club égyptien à
l'aller au Caire Al-Arly euh le
club le plus euh titré du
continent s'est imposé sur le
score de deux à un mais voilà
que le Wydad a donc marqué un
but, il est tenant du titre, il
jouera à domicile dans un stade
Mohamed cinq que tout le monde
connaît hein, un public très
très chaud euh notamment lors
des derbys euh entre euh le
Wydad et le Raja et il a donc
toutes ses chances lui aussi
pourquoi pas de réaliser le
doublé. Rémi, est-ce que malgré
tout le fait de jouer à
domicile c'est avantage au
Casablanca? Beaucoup
d'avantages, surtout que ils
sortent de la tombe, ils
étaient pratiquement dominés
pendant tout le match.
D'ailleurs euh la possession de
hein. Euh parce que lorsque
vous voyez franchement ce
match-là et surtout un but qui
intervient presque à 5 minutes
de la fin du match parce que
euh euh justement Waka a fait
un changement. Vous vous dites
quand même que c'est une équipe
qui a vraiment de la baraka
parce que là juste il venait de
d'éviter le 3 à 0 et d'ailleurs
euh lorsque garder ça vous vous
dites quand même que cette
équipe à domicile elle n'est
pas facile à tenir.
Rappelez-vous la saison
dernière c'était deux zéro et
c'était à domicile. Ouais. Et
là maintenant encore entraîneur
hein. Et c'était avec Et
sachant aussi que. Devenu
sélection quand même quoi qu'on
dise est pratiquement au sommet
en Afrique parce que à part
peut-être l'UMRG qui vient de
faire encore un petit hall de
hop là. Mais ce sont les clubs
marocains aujourd'hui que ce
soit Raja. C'est vrai. Que ce
soit Wa, que ce sont des
équipes qui jouent terriblement
bien et à domicile sont
intenables. donc euh
pratiquement même euh quand
vous partez avec un avantage,
même avec deux zéro, ce n'était
pas garanti. Maintenant avec
deux un, dans un tout petit but
suffira. Ouais. Ce sera très
difficile pour et comme on le
dit un proverbe africain eh
bien chaque chasse se
transforme en tigre devant sa
poule. Hum. Euh Xavier c'est
vrai que en même temps ces deux
clubs actuellement dominent
cette compétition en finale
l'année dernière.
Ça se jouait sur un seul match
les les finales sur un match
voilà et donc là ils reviennent
sur une finale aller-retour
donc l'an dernier d'ailleurs le
Alice était plein que cette
finale euh sur terrain neutre
se joue à Casablanca ce qui
avait été prévu au début de
saison et finalement le wak, le
Wydad était en finale devant
son public donc ils avaient
gagné deux zéro cette fois-ci
euh c'est la finale retour donc
le le Ali a d'un petit but,
c'est pas beaucoup, mais il
faut quand même rappeler
comment le WAC est arrivé là.
Euh c'est quand même un peu un
miracle qui soit là parce que
ils sont qualifiés aux tirs au
but en quart de finale face au
Simba de Tanzanie et face au
ils sont passés au but à
l'extérieur, zéro zéro deux.
Euh qui était euh le favori
après les phases de poule.
Largement. Donc donc du coup,
c'est quand même un club un peu
miraculeux d'arriver jusque là.
Alors c'est vrai qu'ils auront
le soutien de leur public. Euh
mais euh sur ce qu'ils ont
montré dans cette phase à
élimination directe, ils sont
quand même un chanceux déjà
d'être là. Euh est-ce que ils
auront encore un petit coup de
pouce du destin pour aller
l'emporter? Je suis pas sûr
parce que le Ali a vraiment une
envie de de prendre sa
revanche. Hum hum. Il y a
peut-être le facteur X de de ce
match, ça sera euh Peurcy tôt
le le Tao qui euh lui joue dans
les rangs de Al-Arly et qui euh
remet euh amené l'an dernier
par Percimo Siman le le
l'entraîneur euh des Duali euh
qui est resté au club,
l'entraîneur a changé,
maintenant c'est euh euh
Suisse. Mais euh mais lui est
toujours là. C'est un c'est un
joueur extraordinaire et aurait
pu bénéficier d'une exclusion
parce que vous voyez il y a une
action où pratiquement il part
droit au but et il est retenu
par euh euh un joueur là, je ne
sais pas où à euh
carton rouge. C'était un carton
rouge mais on a donné un carton
moi je n'ai pas compris cette
action de jeu-là. Donc Théo il
il filait parce que c'était
direct un face à face mais bon.
C'est pour ça que que cette
équipe du Maroc a eu beaucoup
de circonstances qui permettent
aujourd'hui que c'est ça la
chance des grands vainqueurs.
Dans le Ali, l'équipe
égyptienne vous avez 8 joueurs
qui étaient déjà en finale
l'année dernière donc il y a
vraiment cette rage de de
prendre sa revanche ils ont pas
été récompensés franchement à
l'aller, euh ils méritaient
effectivement de gagner plus
nettement. Hum hum. Ils ont
peut-être perdu leur chance.
Ouais je crois sur le poteau
hein. En tout cas c'est ce
qu'il faudra voir, la finale
dimanche soir, alors euh samedi
vous avez euh, la finale euh,
continentale européenne et
dimanche soir ça sera celle
euh, d'Afrique à vingt-et-une
heures euh, 19 heures en temps
universel au stade de
Casablanca. On continue, on va
parler de ce football européen
qui se régénère de ce football
européen qui fait la place aux
jeunes.
Voilà.
En moins de 6 mois le football
européen s'est retrouvé euh
disons orphelin de ces
légendes. Juste après euh la
Coupe du monde au mois de
décembre donc en fin d'année
dernière Cristiano Ronaldo
quittait le football anglais
quittait Manchester United pour
Al Nasser le club de d'Arabie
Saoudite. Et puis et puis il y
a eu un tir groupé en cette fin
de saison. Lionel Messi quitte
lui le Paris Saint-Germain.
Alors finalement il ne part pas
lui euh au en Arabie Saoudite
mais il euh par il a choisi les
Etats-Unis et le club de
l'Inter euh Miami. Ah oui le
dernier. On a on a non non
Rémi. Qui lui euh abandonne le
Real Madrid pour euh et là
c'est en Arabie Saoudite. On a
Zlatan Ibrahimovic qui lui
arrête complètement, il va
nulle part, il arrête le
football. 41 ans quand même.
Est-ce que euh pour vous euh
Bruno, le le le football
européen tourne une page avec
le départ de de ces légendes?
Où était-elle déjà tournée?
Elle était pas encore tournée
parce qu'il y a quelques mois
de ça, l'UN Messi a quand même
été sacré, champion du monde
avec l'Argentine. Il l'avait
pour ce qui est des des clubs
des joueurs hein, je parle des
joueurs plus que des clubs mais
on a eu pendant pendant plus
d'une décennie le duel euh
entre Cristiano Ronaldo et
Lionel Messi qui a été les le
le plus grand duel de
l'histoire du football avec
sans doute deux des plus grands
joueurs de l'histoire. On
savait que ça allait arriver,
plus les années passées, on
voyait avec pas le déclin de
Cristiano Ronaldo, mais il
s'éloignait quand même du très
haut niveau d'abord avec la
Juve, après un manquement, les
déboires qu'il avait initié et
puis son départ en Arabie
Saoudite. Et puis Lionel Messi
depuis deux ans au PSG, c'était
pas Lionel Messi qu'on avait
connu FC Barcelone. Donc on
plus haut niveau, hein. On
arrivait vraiment à la fin de
de cette et et après il y a eu
effectivement euh, je mettrais
Benzema dans un cas à part
parce qu'il aurait pu donner
encore facilement un ou deux
ans de plus au très haut niveau
euh, pour Ibrahimovic ça
faisait déjà quelques années
que c'était du bonus et on se
régalait de le voir à 40 ans en
Italie et lui il a déjà été aux
États-Unis puisqu'il a passé
trois deux saisons euh, Los
Angeles c'est quelque chose qui
on on le savait, ça fait
quelques années qu'on en parle
mais c'est toujours difficile
de l'admettre parce qu'on
voyait peut-être Messi refaire
peut-être une année au FC
Barcelone euh, peut-être que
Benzema aurait fait un an ou
deux ans de plus au moins un an
de plus jusqu'à l'arrivée
peut-être de Mbappé à la pointe
du de l'attaque du Real Madrid
donc forcément on est un peu
déçus, on est un peu sur notre
fin quoi, on on aurait aimé en
goûter un peu plus de ces de
ces générations en même temps
ou Platini et Maradona ben on
met aujourd'hui plus longtemps
grâce aux soins grâce au
travail physique est-ce que
est-ce que quand euh ces deux
grands qui étaient Cristiano et
et Messi ont ont quitté peu à
peu le le football euh espagnol
hein euh et et la confrontation
directe, est-ce que déjà il y
avait une page qui était disons
en train de se tourner et
qu'elle a mis euh deux trois
ans à à se terminer parce que
effectivement euh les les
Classicos restaient concentrés,
restaient euh focalisés sur la
l'opposition, Christiano
Ronaldo euh Lionel Messi, et
quand Cristiano Rondot est
parti à disons il faut pas
focaliser mais en tout cas il
elle est symbolisée, à chaque
fois on les opposait euh là
quand Cristiano Ronaldo est
parti à la Juve, on a dit ah
bah Lionel Messi n'a plus
d'adversaire, bon en fait il y
avait Benzema qui a pris le
relais et puis euh et puis de
toute façon il y a un moment ou
un autre il faut laisser la
place aux jeunes, il faut
tourner la page. Donc moi je
trouve plutôt bien tournée pour
vous? Oui oui sans problème,
moi je me réjouis de eux qui
aient gagné par exemple la
Ligue des champions.
Mais donc moi je trouve c'est
très bien justement qu'on ait
cette nouvelle vague avec
beaucoup de joueurs de grand
talent notamment parmi les hum
hum. Donc donc euh eux ils
partent grâce à leur notoriété
euh leurs followers sur les
réseaux sociaux et cetera,
apporter de la visibilité sur
d'autres euh championnats, sur
le championnat saoudien, qui
qui est un bon championnat de
du Moyen-Orient apporter de la
visibilité. Ouais.
Pour l'argent. Oui, non mais
eux ils y vont pour l'argent
mais de toute façon ils font
pas ça bénévolement depuis des
années hein. PSG il le fait pas
bénévolement non plus. Donc si
il va pas bénévolement euh oui
non mais après il apporte aussi
de de la euh tu as vu déjà les
les euh les demandes de places
pour les donc ça fait ça fait
partie on a aux États-Unis ils
ont déjà vécu ça dans les
années soixante-dix de d'aller
porter la visibilité en Arabie
Saoudite et aux Etats-Unis.
Leur choix c'est d'aller
prendre de l'argent aux
Etats-Unis et en Arabie
Saoudite. Rémi, est-ce que pour
vous euh cette page euh il y a
il y a une nouvelle page qui
est qui commence à s'écrire euh
dans le football européen? Et
notamment pour ce qui sera la
la prochaine Ligue des
champions euh pour euh la
nouvelle formule aussi de cette
Ligue des champions à partir de
l'année écrit. On a le droit
d'y être écrit. C'est-à-dire?
Parce que on va constater que
Ronaldo ou Ronaldo? Cristiano
ou Ronaldo? Parce que non non
non européen retiendra que le
plus grand buteur de la Ligue
des champions reste Cristiano
Ronaldo avec 141 buts suivi de
Messi 129 buts. Le football
européen retiendra peut-être le
footballeur européen retiendra
que Cristiano Ronaldo c'est
quarante-et-un euh sept pages
décisives
Européens, est-ce que les
championnats passent à autre
chose? Ah on doit passer à
autre chose que c'est difficile
également de passer à autre
chose parce que comme je vous
ai dit j'avais dit ici c'est
facile d'être dans un club et
de gagner. Mais lorsqu'on
déménage, ça devient compliqué.
On disait déjà que l'époque
Ronaldo était finie, lorsqu'il
était parti à la Juve, mais on
retiendra quand même que lui
dans plusieurs endroits,
c'est-à-dire qu'en Manchester
United il est le seul joueur
d'ailleurs au monde à avoir
dans des clubs européens marqué
plus de 100 buts. Que ce soit
Manchester United, que ce soit
au Real, que ce soit à la Juve
et peut-être aussi avec la
sélection nationale, pas
peut-être certainement avec la
sélection maintenant lorsqu'on
essaie de voir ce qui va se
passer, bien évidemment moi je
peux vous dire
la relève. Je peux déjà vous
parler de Vinicius qui incarne
la relève parce que je ne peux
pas manquer du respect à Messi
parce que Messi quand même faut
le reconnaître à 22 ans avait
déjà un ballon d'or. Lorsqu'on
voit maintenant la précocité
des Venus dans les buts et
surtout au des passes
décisives, l'impact qu'il a. On
se dit que il a toutes les
capacités pour pouvoir faire
quelque chose. Par contre, je
suis je ne suis pas de celle-là
qui bien évidemment vont nous
dire que non Erling Allan c'est
un parce que moi je vais vous
dire seulement que j'ai vu
l'année de Messi. Ça c'est
vrai. Je ne veux pas prendre
Ronaldo parce que c'est un
joueur à qui je donne toujours
la couronne. Mais quand je vois
seulement 2011, je vois Lionel
Messi et soixante-treize buts
avec trente-six passes de six
et on est en train de me parler
des des autres
je suis cités avec lui pour
Vénissieux. Euh un l'un de nos
auditeurs euh de Jean euh il y
a Norma euh Basi lui il nous le
dit certes il y a de bons
joueurs comme Mbappé Halande
euh et cetera mais la
génération Messi Ronaldo reste
et restera la meilleure. Ils se
trompent. Ils se trompent parce
que l'histoire du football fait
que il y a eu des générations
il y a eu Zidane euh, Rivaldo,
Beckham, et puis maintenant il
y avait il y avait
effectivement Messi, Cristiano
Ronaldo
Mais mais mais maintenant moi
je pense qu'il y a 5 joueurs,
cinq joueurs qui vont dominer
les prochaines années. Donc je
suis d'accord avec Rémi Gonaud
pour Vinicius. Il y a Mbappé
bien sûr, il y a à Nantes. Et
moi je rajoute aux hymens et
Rashford. Voilà, je pense que
c'est les cinq têtes d'affiche
qui vont dominer les prochaines
années et dès l'automne
prochain vous allez voir la
Ligue des champions, les gens
ont oublié Messi et Cristiano
Ronaldo et ils vont dire ce
sera qui? Ce sera Mbappé, ce
sera aux hymens, ce sera
Rashford, ce sera Vinicius ou
bien euh ce sera euh qui
cinquième que je à voilà.
Trésor de Kinshasa euh nous dit
d'abord bonjour à tous et
bonjour à Rémy surtout hein,
nous euh c'est pas grave. Il
dit euh Vinicius à Londres
Rodrigo, Belingham et Courtois
qui peuvent maintenant gagner
surtout des ballons surtout
courtois c'est c'est
d'excellents joueurs, c'est des
super joueurs mais c'est on est
là on parle de on est au-dessus
là mais mais si Ronaldo ils
sont au-dessus ils sont ça
faisait 15 ans qu'ils étaient
en haut de la montagne,
personne ne les a atteints,
personne personne et tu parlais
de l'histoire de l'avant, de
Platini, de Beckham, de
Maradona et cetera, il y en a
certaines qui se sont
approchées mais sur une telle
longévité, on a vu ça dans qui
là selon vous? Pour moi ils
pour moi ils sont ils seront
iront ils sont iront passables,
je sais pas si quelques uns
vont s'approcher de leur
niveau, je sais pas si il va y
avoir autant de Ballon d'or un
joueur comme Cana aujourd'hui
pour Messi? Je sais
on
parle de tourner la page
mais le prochain ballon d'or ce
sera peut-être le Nel Messi et
on parlera encore de Liam Messi
qui sera encore le le le roi
sur sur cette planète football.
Oui mais c'est qui s'approche
évidemment avec euh Paris
Saint-Germain à Londres.
Qu'est-ce que vous êtes en
train de raconter je suis
d'accord avec Vincent Mbappé en
Vénissieux les jeunes euh
pépites de pension. Du côté de
Barcelone. Mais c'est des bons
joueurs. Mais c'est pas du
niveau de Messi. Messieurs pas
encore. Non mais Messi,
Ronaldo, c'était deux joueurs
qui faisaient gagner leurs
équipes. Aujourd'hui, pour moi,
il n'a pas un seul qui existe.
En dehors de ces deux-là, il
n'a pas un seul. Il y a aucun
joueur a gagné la Ligue des
Champions avec le PSG? Il a
amené le PSG en finale oui mais
il a pas amené jusqu'à la Ligue
des champions. Ils sont allés
en finale. Ils l'ont pas gagné.
Hum. C'est bien ce que je dis.
Mais c'est ça la force de
Ronaldo et Messi c'est qu'il
faisait gagner leurs équipes.
Oui mais d'accord avec toi. Que
si est un joueur et et et tout
à fait exceptionnelle.
Nous le nous le répète à chaque
et à chaque émission, il a pas
gagné la Ligue des champions
depuis 2015. Euh et Cristiano
Ronaldo est parti du Real
Madrid et le Real Madrid a
quand même gagné la Ligue des
champions sans lui. Donc les
grands joueurs marquent
l'histoire, mais un jour ou
l'autre, on tourne la page et
ils sont remplacés pareil avec
Messi et Christiane Ronaldo. Eh
bien cette nouvelle page dans
le football européen, vous la
suivrez grâce à Radio Foot
International et grâce au Café
des Sports. Allez, on compte et
on va vers les cartons du jour.
Carton jaune! Un carton jaune.
Oh là là là là! Carton rouge!
Carton rouge! Dans la
confusion. Carton vert! Et trop
extraordinaire! Rien à dire!
Vos cartons, chers auditeurs et
internautes sélectionnés par le
grand David Fizel. Bienvenue
dans un club de légendes où
règne la technique, le talent,
la responsabilité. Donc, la
fondation de ce club repos sur
les épaules d'un jeune depuis
un certain moment, son nom
c'est carrément.
Titre c'est pas facile hein,
c'est pas facile hein. À toutes
les choses qu'il y a à faire
dans une période de 14 ans à
notre club de coeur Real Madrid
donc euh merci beaucoup à lui
et bonne continuité à lui, à la
club de Arabie Saoudite. Nous
les madrillets nous te disons
merci. C'est pas facile hein.
C'est pas facile hein Tu seras
une légende. C'est pas facile
Salut là de foot international
c'est Ibrahim depuis la
Mauritanie. Mon carton est
rouge et il va directement aux
supporters du Paris
Saint-Germain pour leur manque
de respect envers Lionel Messi.
Certes les choses ne sont pas
passées comme prévues au Paris
Saint-Germain et dans la vie on
n'a pas toujours ce qu'on veut
mais quand même l'ennemi se
mérite d'être respecté non
seulement pour sa carrière mais
pour tout ce qu'il a apporté au
football. Merci une émission à
tous. Bonjour café des sports.
C'est carton rouge pour euh le
qui a laissé tout un club
espérer un retour de et ils
savaient très bien que Messi
n'allait pas revenir au pièger.
Laissez une preuve se démerder
ou faire revenir ses joies.
C'était pas garanti, tu vois
également. Salut. Bonjour Radio
Foot. Bonjour je suis Moïse, je
suis depuis le Cameroun. Je
donne un carton rouge
aujourd'hui à l'Arabie
Saoudite. Qui essaye de faire
briller sa ligue par le haut en
recrutant de grosses stars
alors qu'il devrait comment à
la basse qui sont en train
d'imiter la Chine qui est
passée par là et a échoué. Ça
sera aussi un échec. Salut!
Je donne un carton rouge aux
dirigeants de le plus grand
club du Togo qui menotte ces
joueurs parce que les jours
réclament des salaires impayés
même si les dirigeants
évoquaient notre thèse mais
c'est c'est très décevant de
voir comment les joueurs sont
minotés mais et amenés au
commissariat on dirait des
volets. Non ce n'est pas bon,
ce représentatif de ce grand
club du Togo, carton rouge aux
dirigeants de. Bonsoir Radio
Foot International. C'est
Castro Florent depuis la
République Démocratique du
Congo, précisément le je donne
mon carton rouge à l'Outaouais
Martinez et à Lucas pour qu'il
mette d'alerte. Demain nous
serons derrière et pour leur
pousser à la victoire.
Interdit, Milan, Vamous,
Vamous, Vamous. Bonsoir. Radio
Foot International. bonsoir à
la grande présentatrice
que le tacticien catalan juste
un abeillement pour la finale
de samedi, je lui demande de
rester prudent, d'être patient
comme on l'a souvent remarqué
cette année, surtout lors de la
grande compétition qui est la
ligue des champions. Donc, si
tu as besoin de ce trophée,
coach, ne t'apprenez surtout
pas. Foot international, moi
c'est Moïse depuis Congo
Kinshasa. Mon carton, il est
jeune à moi-même. Pourquoi?
Parce que aujourd'hui où je
vois les terres de Majesté par
la question que je me pose avec
tout ce que j'ai vu avec
Majesté si tu as fait la carte
des fées comment elle peut
jouer un tel match sans marquer
un but alors je crois pas à mon
rêve je crois même pas je crois
même pas carton jaune dans ma
meuf.
C'est leur plus grande séquence
des cartons
Allez euh Rémy N'Gono, quelle
est euh la couleur de votre
carton aujourd'hui? Carton
vert! Ah Jean-Louis Gassel,
sélectionneur des éléphants,
bon évidemment, il a fait une
déclaration qui peut paraître
dénigrante pour le football
africain en disant que il voit
aucun joueur du championnat
ivoirien postuler à la
sélection nationale dont ils
n'ont pas de niveau. Eh bien
les gens veulent se plaindre
que il y a de bons joueurs et
puis c'est la vérité qu'il dit.
Vous n'organisez pas de bons
championnats en Afrique
subsaharienne. La preuve c'est
qu'on voit nos clubs
aujourd'hui qui ne parviennent
pas à aller comme d'autres
clubs dans des hautes
compétitions. Vous vendez
rapidement les petits poussins,
la poule, aller en Europe et
c'est eux qui constituent le
noyau de la sélection
nationale. Il a dit la vérité,
Jean-Louis Gasset, il faut que
le football ivoirien, le
football africain revienne à
des bases, à savoir organiser
des compétitions slo mais
malheureusement cette vérité-là
risque de lui coûter très cher
parce qu'il y a un proverbe
africain qui dit que le bébé ne
croque pas le sang de la mère
nourricière. Ouais nous en gros
on dit faut pas cracher dans la
soupe mais bon. Ça serait plus.
Bruno Constant. Carton vert à
David Moïse, l'entraîneur de
West Ham qui a gagné la Ligue
Europa conférence avec le club
londonien. Euh ça fait 25 ans
qu'il est sur un banc, c'est
son premier titre majeur, son
seul trophée jusqu'à présent.
C'était un titre de de Détroit
Anglaise avec et voilà euh,
c'est un entraîneur magnifique
euh, et je suis très content
pour lui, soixante ans comme
quoi un chouette passion.
Xavier Barré. Vert aussi, on
est de bonne humeur
aujourd'hui, carton vert en
football italien et en
particulier au à la formation
des jeunes. Euh, les Atsoulini
sont en finale du mondial des
20 ans en Argentine après avoir
sorti euh, la Corée du Sud euh,
euh, sur un coup franc d'un
d'un petit jeune de Loudinez
euh, finalement le football
italien après un grand creux
euh, revient dans avec des
succès dans les compétitions de
jeunes, c'est de bon augure
pour l'avenir. Et ça sera la
finale contre l'Uruguay hein,
n'est-ce pas la euh des jeunes.
Le carton de Radio Foot
International, eh bien il est
vert lui aussi et il va, vous
allez voir, aux ultras du
Napoli, qui ont offert à
spaletti l'entraîneur qui est
euh partant cadeau de départ,
une Fiat Panda qu'en fait il
lui avait subtilisé euh quand
il était arrivé en lui
demandant euh de partir et de
quitter les lieux, il voulait
que l'entraîneur s'en aille et
là, ils lui ont offert quoi?
Ont offert le volant de sa Fiat
Panda. Vous voyez les images,
ils étaient là cagoulés, tout
comme des vrais ultras. Et
c'était euh le cadeau euh pour
euh le récompenser du titre du
Napoli et de ce scooter. Et
puis pour terminer l'émission,
eh bien je vous demande de dire
euh bon anniversaire à David
Finzel aujourd'hui. Joyeux
anniversaire.
Merci à tous, merci, bon
anniversaire David et à la
semaine prochaine.